the world has fundamentally changed
since the first spreadsheet the first
major spreadsheet Excel was built and
then since even Google Sheets Google
Sheets was released 16 years ago the way
we work now the way we have access to
data the way we work as teams is
fundamentally different
um and so you know the BET behind equals
is
what would it look like to build a
spreadsheet that fits this era's work
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
Bobby Pinero welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
how are you I'm doing great thanks for
having me Michael really appreciate it
awesome to have you here you're working
on on a startup which is in an industry
that I I really love I love it I love
you know SAS I love data I love
connecting to data sources I love when
people do it for me so that I can
extract insights and and so I already
love equals soon I'm gonna love it even
more because I'm gonna know the story
behind the equals but before we get into
that tell me a little bit about yourself
Bobby a little bit about your upbringing
and what has sort of LED you to start
this to start this company
yeah
um well so uh I'm uh originally I was
born in Puerto Rico uh and I lived there
for the first four or five years of my
life and moved uh out to the move to the
U.S moved to uh Washington DC area I
grew up there
um and I remember I bought my I saved up
the first job I had it was a lifeguard
uh and before that I worked my mom was
an accountant and I used to go into our
office and uh do just like little random
accounting tasks that she would pay me
to do and all I wanted to do was save up
to buy a computer and to be able to get
online and to be able to
play computer games and uh you know just
have my own have my own computer it's up
always have been kind of uh just really
eager and excited to be a part of the
internet and be playing with computers
um and so Tech has always been just a a
kind of passion and an interest of mine
and then
um you know I have the great Fortune of
going to Stanford for college
took a class there
which uh really kind of
I don't know uh gave me the kind of
entrepreneurial bug or kind of really
fortified stuff for me it was the it was
this uh engineering entrepreneurship
class that taught by a guy named Steve
blank who it was in over the course of
10 weeks you had to start your own
startup yeah
I loved it that was like by far and away
at the end of the 10 weeks you had to
pitch VCS and like that was that was it
I was like that's what I want to do
um this was really it was really really
fun
and um and so
um you know after college I went and
joined IBM a massive massive massive
company learned I heard about it I think
yeah learned in two years that working
in a 400 000 person company is not my
jam
um and then kind of progressively worked
my way into smaller companies uh joined
a startup like 100 person startup after
leaving IBM and then joined
um God luck and join intercom uh when it
was 20 people
uh spent eight years there built
intercom from 20 people to 700 people
from less than a million an AR to uh you
know a couple hundred million in ARR and
then
um you know I just feel like I've been
progressing towards uh this kind of
point in my journey of being able to
start my own thing and
um
you know now I feel fully aligned to I
feel like this is exactly what I'm
supposed to be doing
what what does that mean you know I I
that you feel like you're doing what you
think you're supposed to be doing
let's let's unlock that statement a
little bit if you will
yeah
um
but I think for me you know
um what I've always
there is so I've been in kind of Finance
analytical type roles for the last
decade
um and I am a very analytical person I
am somebody who likes to work in numbers
and data but there's also a part of me
and uh you know maybe one a part of me
that wasn't fed as much by the roles I
was in previously
um a part of me that that is really
creative and uh loves to bring a part of
myself to the world and kind of express
myself in these creative ways and learn
not just what it what it's like to run a
business from an analytical point of
view but what it's like to
Market something to sell something to
build product to
um you know
um kind of touch all facets of the
business and so
um this
equals first and foremost is like the
true extensive it's like the thing I
wish had existed for myself it's this
passion project to try to help people
that are in roles that I'm in it's also
this creative expression of you know
myself my co-founder Ben uh the broader
team uh it's our you know our mark on
the world and
um that's I've what I've known I've
wanted to do for a long long time and so
um when I'd say it's a line to to kind
of
what I want to be working on that's what
I mean
all right so let's let's dive into the
the formation of equals no paint paint
me a picture of the world two years ago
you're thinking about you know
going about a journey
let's let's sort of you know unfold the
story of what you understood that that
led to the to the realization of equals
yeah
um
so equals comes from you know like I
said I I've been an analyst for the last
decade uh this is you know I've been in
the role of the people that we're trying
to you know solve a lot of pain for
um and so uh there's a there's maybe a
few kind of uh seeds that were planted
um I'll tell you a couple stories one is
at IBM we use this tool called essbase
it's an oracle product uh there's a
plug-in to Excel and it's this olap Cube
that basically you can
uh with the click of a button import any
data that you want into your Excel
workbook and it has magic it's like you
know oh my God made it made my life so
easy as an analyst to be able to pull
something in no it was right know where
it came from know that I can reproduce
it at any point in time because I know
you know the dimensions upon which I
pulled this into my my spreadsheet
and so uh the the thing was at IBM we
had I don't know how many tens of
Engineers managing this Oracle s space
instance for like a team of like you
know 40 50 Finance folks
um and so
just not a reasonable thing for any
startup to have yeah then
um
I went to another company kind of didn't
have these tools it was painful I was
building all these like forecast models
and things like that spending far too
much of my time just updating them
maintaining them every Friday at
intercom for example we did this weekly
forecast review I'd spent three hours
every morning running SQL queries
updating my model I'd forget to update a
query I'd spend the next two hours
trying to reproduce the query that I had
used the last week to make the model
right because our data had somehow
changed et cetera et cetera
so there's all that pain that like you
know I'd live for the last decade
and then
but the the fundamental thesis behind
equals is that
the spreadsheet's actually the best way
to do analyzes people want a spreadsheet
and
you know my other big big big
frustration as an analyst over the last
decade is just being pitched every data
tool and every data tool basically falls
into every new data tool that's emerged
falls into one of three categories
yet another bi tool yeah and like God
help us if we need another bi tool
notebooks
right and notebooks are interesting
there's some really cool ones out there
but notebooks are you know they really
serve a tiny tiny tiny fraction of the
population of people doing analyzes
and then there's like these spreadsheet
Alternatives which are like you know
trying to wage war against the
spreadsheet and it's like oh we'll give
you some other way some simpler way to
model your business and
you know I'm like no I don't want I like
the spreadsheet the spreadsheet's great
most people like the spreadsheet they
know how to use it they've built their
career off of learning how to use a
spreadsheet how to build it it's
flexible it's this like magical canvas
that lets you paint and move data around
and touch and feel it and build
compounding things and so armhole bed is
a spreadsheet's not wrong it's actually
right
but
the world has fundamentally changed
since the first spreadsheet the first
major spreadsheet Excel was built and
then since even Google Sheets Google
Sheets was released 16 years ago the way
we work now the way we have access to
data the way we work as teams is
fundamentally different
um and so you know the BET behind equals
is
what would it look like to build a
spreadsheet that fits this era's work
yeah
and so let's talk a little bit about the
product and and the connectedness to to
data sources that's something that you
know obviously is a is a big deal here
in in a world and and perhaps we can
start with just a little bit about you
know what what I as a as a startup you
know perhaps
um experiencing in terms of the way that
my data is structured and how we can
actually leverage that to build the next
evolution of what Excel should be yeah
so
you know we've
um we started with data connecting with
data
um because that's just a really obvious
and painful part of working in in
spreadsheets today and it's a really
painful part of how
every everybody from analysts to
Founders to marketing Ops to sales Ops
to Biz Ops and
um marketers in general a lot of pain uh
felt kind of across the board there
um but I guess the thing I'd say is
um
the one of the magical Parts about
equals particularly for kind of uh
startups uh who we're kind of focused on
first is
there's not another data tool on the
planet that lets you actually connect to
multiple different data sources and work
with them all in one place and so if
you're a Founder you you haven't gone
through the process of
uh consolidating all of your data into
one data warehouse right like Founders
startups have not
higher builds bought five Tran they've
not
implemented DBT they haven't put all of
their data into a data warehouse and
built these like you know uh uh big flat
tables that then they can join up really
nicely and they don't have all these
analytics Engineers that are like you
know pulling it all and combining it for
them nicely so real the reality of like
a Founder is if you want to build an
analysis that looks at your funnel
you're going to Google analytics for
your traffic you may be going to
mixpanel to understand what's happening
in your funnel and then you're going to
strike to see who actually paid you and
doing that is this like manual nightmare
it's like okay I'm gonna log into all
these different places and the results
of that is you won't do it as often as
you should you might do it once a month
you might do it once every couple of
weeks because it's really annoying to do
but with equals you just plug equals
directly into GA to mix panel to stripe
and then you can use all your
spreadsheet formulas the things that you
already know how to do to smash it all
together to build to build that
um that funnel view for yourself and
then you can update it as many times as
you want as often as you want
daily hourly
um and so you just have a much better
view of kind of what's going on in your
business and you've done so in a tool
that's really easy to use that you
essentially already know how to use
so how much of it is a sort of a view
only versus you know editable
interactive Studio because it sounds
like a lot of this data is being pulled
in I'm curious from a product
perspective how do you how do you
transition from a from a passive a
reading mechanism to a more active
participatory you know data engineering
type mindset
well that's actually the the most
beautiful part about equals and there
you go I know what to ask
um well if you think think about like bi
tools for example if there was a if you
could build your entire funnel analysis
in a bi tool that's great uh and you can
look at it and one of the most common
things that happens after you build a
funnel it out build a dashboard in any
bi tool is
great but now what happens when this
when I want to do this or okay that's
great yeah I see what conversion is
today but what is what is the lead
volume going to be tomorrow when we do
this marketing campaign or a month from
now or three months from now how many
leads we have to get to get to this
number and so guess what you take all
that data from your bi till you download
it into a spreadsheet and you do that
analysis and so the power of equals is
that it's actually gives you that the bi
functionality it allows you to build
these automated views into your business
but then you can right there alongside
that automated view not have to go to
another tool not have to download this
other thing you can build out your
analysis from there right there
alongside it because you have a
spreadsheet yeah I love it so so
obviously you know you're you're you're
the beginning of what sounds like a
pretty a pretty cool you know journey
and definitely something that I can you
know as a potential customer I can see
the I can I can see the various use
cases as you as you're taking over the
the experiences that you've had at
intercom and IBM et cetera and prior
you've experienced hyper growth SAS uh
personally well what are you taking with
you sort of as a something to keep in
the back of your mind sort of as the you
know sort of the chief in command here
um
as you're going about building and
scaling equals around you know from your
previous experiences
yeah
um oh man so many lessons
um I think the you know uh
the uh some of the things that are I'm
taking with me are
um look like startups especially at our
stage in the early days of intercom for
example it's so much about how quickly
you move you're not going to be right on
many things that you do you're gonna
like this is a iterating game this is a
try as fast as you can as many different
things as you possibly can see what
works
um and so the thing that we're you know
we continue to talk about internally is
how do we just how do we try as much as
we possibly can as fast as we can how do
we continue to drive you know we close
the series a and the last thing I want
that to do for the team is drive any
sort of create any sort of complacency
or feelings like hey we've made it or
we've figured something out uh We've not
and we gotta go we gotta keep going and
we gotta
um you know move even faster now uh uh
as we kind of uh hire more folks and
um
uh um you know get to a different level
of skill so uh speed is something I
think a lot about and I think something
we did really really well in the early
intercom days
um
and then
you know it really just comes down to
I know this will sound simple but it it
really comes down to the quality and the
types of folks that you bring onto the
team uh like the team is everything and
so
um you know one of the things that we
did at intercom that I thought was
really well was just hire
for people with a you know it sounds
um
you know it's it's it's cliche but it's
uh with a with a steep slope right it's
people who are on a trajectory in their
career who are really motivated who are
really hungry who are really
um uh gonna go kind of work hard and go
above and beyond and see this as an
opportunity to take a huge step in their
career as opposed to just a kind of
another
um you know just another another job
um and so hiring is is something that
we're focused on keeping the bar for who
we hire and who we keep it equals and
insanely I
I love that higher higher with the steep
slope
I'm gonna take that with me I think I'm
gonna tell that to my co-founder after
this so thank you thank you thank you
for that already tell me a little bit
about how you know where you are in in
this journey and how does this fit into
sort of your vision of yourself as an
entrepreneur
yes
I am uh
I'm in the you know learning uh how to
be a you know we we're now 11 folks the
plan is to by the end of next year
um you know be anywhere between 30 to 40
folks uh so we're gonna hire pretty
aggressively I think that you know I've
managed teams this big before at
intercom but one of the challenges for
me now is what does it mean to be CEO at
this scale
um what are the types of things that I
should be working on what are the types
of things that I shouldn't be working on
uh how do I you know plant seeds within
the company so that and then kind of
nourish them so that they can take on as
many things as they possibly can and do
their best work
um and so you know just trying to kind
of figure out how I work uh as a leader
how I kind of
um evolve into this next step uh as a
CEO and there will be many many more
steps uh beyond that
that's awesome all right my favorite
question that I that I am always waiting
to moments of delight in your own world
you know in your own day-to-day
um you know if you're thinking about you
know what really gets you in this flow
you know the most effortless
moments of in in the journey will well
how you know what what comes to mind
um
certainly uh when our customers uh reach
out to us and you know share some story
about how equals somehow made their life
better or uh how they're excited about a
new feature that we shipped or how they
uh shared it with somebody else in their
organization and they got excited about
it and built something in equals like
those are those are the moments where I
feel I guess maybe the most fulfilled
and the most and maybe a little bit
different angle than what you were
asking but those are the moments where I
feel the most grad uh gratitude and
fulfillment and excitement for for what
we're working on because
again for me the most important thing
with equals you know obviously we want
to build a big company obviously we want
to have a big impact on the world you
know we want to build we want to
create great returns for our investors
for ourselves but the thing that's most
most most important for me is uh
just helping analysts and it's like all
the pain that I've lived as an analyst
it's like I want to I want to help them
I want to make their lives better I want
to give them a tool that's built for
them that's fun that's light on their
fingertips that's joyous to use that's
you know for all the like Engineers got
GitHub designers got figma product
managers and you know other folks got
like tools like notion and Coda that
they're excited about and they get to
work in all day every day
us like
Finance people Biz Ops people analysts
type folks we've been stuck in Excel for
40 years like where's our tool where's
our tool so that's that's the thing I'm
most excited about
um
and then uh
just in terms of Flow State for me I
think you know uh
the thing that helps me the most there
is just being really really intentional
and deliberate every day about what I'm
working on and what's the biggest
priority because there's so many things
that can happen and so
it's being really clear about what I'm
not working on and what I am working on
and that if I can if I can get very
clear on that then it's actually just
much easier for me to kind of flow into
what I'm doing
I really really love that Bobby thank
you so much for your time and for your
energy I really look forward to cheering
from the side on the Journey of equals I
appreciate everything and take care and
and best of luck with this amazing
journey thanks Michael thanks for having
me on and yeah any feedback on equals uh
we'd love to hear it I'll be I'll be
I'll be ready to give it thank you very
much thank you thank you